for spring and sunshine over here too
and it's time to update update our
wardrobe make sure we are looking fresh
for the new season and here to help us
do just that is to lisa breslin from the
district at green valley ranch how are
you good thanks for having me here
thanks for letting me feel and touch
everything i was ready these sunglasses
caught my eye right away so let's just
jump right into it where are these from
where can people get these yeah those
sunglasses are actually from brighton
they're called the toledo alto
sunglasses they're similar to aviators
but with a little bit of sass they have
like some ring stones on the side so
they're perfect for spring
also we have a couple of outfits from
white house black market and take off
the sunglasses so i can see everything
else that you've got okay let's start
down here these are so cute yeah they
have bulb patterns and
stripes which are very popular this
season yeah um so and then we also can
complete the look with some um
accessories from
brighton and this is that um calypso
tote bag that is hand painted that's so
cute it's the perfect pop of color yeah
some of the black and white with it yeah
exactly and then we have some jewelry
from pandora which they're featuring a
blue butterfly
collection this season i pick for spring
right yeah and then we also have lush
cosmetics on site and they are jumping
into spring with their whole array of
easter
themed products like that um
bunny backpack gift set so cute and it
smells so good it was the first thing
delicious i noticed after the sunglasses
because i just like to see and smell and
touch everything was the i mean you can
smell lush from a mile away anywhere you
are it's the best yeah i love working
there because the smell is like so good
yes every time i go in i just have to
put some lotion on and it's just so
refreshing especially for spring as you
head into a new season your skin's
changing and over here i love a good hat
where is this look from that is from
bloom boutique which is a very small
curated boutique so you would only find
one of a kind pieces that is a designer
spring dress and then that hat is from
gigi pip which is very popular lately uh
perfect for spring so cute i could see
the hat with the sunglasses the back i
mean you can just get a little bit of
everything and complete the look that's
what i love about the district at green
valley ranch you have a little bit of
everything and then you can be in
fashion and you could go you know enjoy
a lunch or a patio dinner let's talk
about some of the other things you guys
have at the district yeah well the
district has a little bit of everything
for everyone from you know shopping to
restaurants that are very curated one of
a kind
in a beautiful outdoor setting and right
now it's blooming there so it's a great
place to go this spring yeah it's the
perfect time to get there get all this
stuff i can't set these down because
they're just so cute so i'm gonna put it
back on we are ready to shop you can
check out all of this stuff at the
district at green valley ranch i do a
lot of my shopping there so i'm excited
to see what's in season thank you so
much thanks for having me thanks for
keeping us fashionable and yeah of
course mercedes i'll send it over to you